See that cute little dog in the pet store window?
Chances are it came from a puppy mill,...
...a breeding facility that forces caged, neglected, and often sick dogs...
...to churn out puppy after puppy to be sold for profit.
That's how nearly all pet stores work.
Meanwhile, millions of wonderful healthy pets end up in animal shelters...
...because of divorce, money trouble, or simply not having a home.
Animal shelters are full of amazing pets looking for a home.
Mixed, pure breed, big or small, puppies to adults,...
...you can find that faithful companion you've always wanted.
A fluffy snuggler, your new hiking buddy, or even one that looks good in hats.
When you adopt your new best friend, not only are you saving a life,...
...you're taking a stand against puppy mills.